have over a year since season one of
stranger things premiered so figurehead
why not review it review it before
season 2 so I'll catch you guys in 2018
to review season 2 I don't know maybe
we'll see what happens probably not that
[Music]
stranger things season 1 part of this
complete breakfast the strangest thing
season 1 is a Netflix original series
when it came out it just exploded it
went wild so by the time I was going to
see it like I said the hype was real
ever have something be so overhyped that
you just have to wait until the hype
train dies down before you watch it as
like that so I had to wait until the
hype train died down before I watched
stranger things season 1 since then up
watch it about three times and I'm
really glad I waited on this because
stranger things is excellent it would
have been a shame to have it overhyped
by the time I watched it apparently time
fades even legend and overhyped so
strategy things is pretty much it starts
out as a missing kid story there's a
group of kids they play D&D together and
one of them gets snatched by this thing
you get a glimpse of it it's like a
monster the monster the kids would later
call the demagogues after that the story
follows a few different people there's
the kids mom played by Winona Ryder
there's this sheriff play by David
Harbor there's a group of the kids
friends that it mostly revolves around
these friends find this little girl
named eleven her name is eleven they
call her Elle she can apparently do some
amazing things if not stranger things
there's the missing kids brother and a
love triangle with this cute girl and a
bully it sounds a little more high
school than it actually is point is it's
quite amazing by amazing it is a Stephen
King story it's not a Stephen King story
but when watching this I was I cannot
not see Stephen King it's so clearly a
Stephen King story from Stephen King
news prime which is funny because Finn
wolfhard
in stranger things was also in it by
Stephen King yes he just likes those
stories and someone in the show makes a
Stephen King reference and it all just
made sense now if you didn't know
stranger things is ultimately an 80s
throwback an 80s nostalgia trip an 80
story taking place in the 80s which is a
big thing right now
looks like 80s nostalgia vomit is its
own genre sometimes it works sometimes
it's just beat you over the head you're
like yeah I get what you're doing and I
kind of don't like it it's just it's too
forced but how stranger things does it
is the way that works for me and that is
it's an 80 story that takes place in the
80s that looks like it was made by
someone who loves stories from the 80s
which if you look at the movies of the
80s there's a lot to love but more than
that it looks like a story that fits in
the 80s but just couldn't be made in the
80s I know the story was thought up well
past the 80s but it feels like a story
that could have been
in the 80s that took place in the 80s
but it was limited by the 80s point is
the story of stranger things does lend
itself to all that 80s nostalgia and
taking place in the 80s but having the
freedom to do what they wanted to do
making the show how they wanted to make
it at the 80s just wouldn't have allowed
like I said and no stranger things was
thought up and written well after the
80s I'm just telling you what it feels
like not what it is now first of all
David Harper plays the sheriff he's this
small-town sheriff that's looking for
this kid David Harbor is great he has
his own past his own backstory his own
damage at the show slowly revealed and
really everyone was great I heard what
no no writer there were a few people who
were like I didn't like her she annoyed
me in the show she never annoyed me I
thought she was actually quite good
surprisingly good her character is a bit
batshit but that's not on Winona Ryder
that's on the character but through that
lens I like what they did with her
character because you listened to her
character talking you're like you're
clearly crazy she believes her son's
alive talking to her through the lights
it's a show called stranger things she's
probably not nuts but you understand
that everyone thinks she's nuts and in
her grasp to believe that her son is
alive you do by the fact that she would
buy that fact they're just bummed out
that when David Harbor the sheriff is
there the lights don't just light up and
start answering yes or no questions
they're probably save a lot of time also
glad Matthew Modine kind of got a
mulligan we saw him in Dark Knight Rises
we were like well okay but he was good
as the government dick but they use all
the kids in this show they are what make
it it's very et in its execution the
kids that know more the truth and the
adults know because they have the
imagination to actually grasp that straw
however like et unlike a lot of shows
and movies are like yeah we're harkening
back to the 80s the kids curse and they
talk [ __ ] the kids act like kids with no
adults around there's clearly a divide
the kids on this side adults on this
side it's just childhoods the way it is
shown ales that I also love the fact
that the spectrum that they're viewing
this through is all Dungeons & Dragons
really the entire show is applicable to
Dungeons & Dragons and Dungeons &
Dragons metaphor it's a D&D adventure
that they're on and for me to say the
kids have bright futures ahead of them a
year after the show came out it's kind
of a no-shit statement yeah I know kid
and they have futures ahead of them they
also have bright futures behind them at
this point cuz I'm late on my review any
that chose to be so but stranger things
also does really well is have a good
balance of intrigue and revelation you
want to intrigue people you want to keep
them hooked you don't want to keep
everything from them you get a glimpse
of something and you have another
question you get a glimpse of something
else you have an answer but you also
have a question and yes stranger things
Steele was an alternate-dimension that's
fascinating to me but the different
pockets the different groups of people
all chasing the same thing whether they
know it or not but if their information
a bit of their social circle kind of
bleed together but not totally it's just
enough to be linked facts if they all
got into a room and they were like okay
let's just talk about what we've found
they would have solved this thing like
day two or three however they just don't
know to do that and one of the things
that pleasantly surprised me the most is
the bully art yes there are high school
students social circles and a romance so
yes it was gonna be a bullet funny thing
is you think it's going to go this
obvious ass unbelieveable direction and
really doesn't the bully in the shows
not a villain bully he's not a bully for
the sake of bully there are bullies like
that in here but he's not it he actually
has a fleshed out arc he grows he grows
as a character he grows on you I was
really surprised I don't like bullies so
it's a thing by the end of it to be like
I've kind of see where you're coming
from couple times he does dick out but I
gotta remember he's a high school
student there is a part in this show
where the sheriff and Winona Ryder go
and talk to somebody but I call
exposition lady because that's what she
is therefore she's trying to play okay
here's some information and then here's
all of the information I feel like the
show is just more intriguing when you
were piecing it together yourself I
would have liked it more if you just
didn't get these hard answers from her
maybe you could have saved the
information she gave for season two but
I'm sure they didn't know they were
gonna get a season two I'm just saying
if the show didn't give you that
information it would have changed the
outcome you still would have pieced
enough together to be intrigued and
pretty fulfilled but it doesn't actually
compromise the whole of stranger things
guys in the end stranger things is
exactly what it intended to be probably
more it's a very legit validated story
that takes place in the 80s has 80s
nostalgia eighties style and quality
filmmaking not 80s nostalgia vomit it
has great characters that has great
intrigue the climax of this when it hits
like the last 20 minute mark of the last
episode some of the most fulfilling
tear-inducing moments you'll fail it's
just it's just very emotional
everything's coming together I loved it
I can't wait to see where the characters
go I can't wait to find out more about
the upside down if you haven't seen
stranger things season one yet treat
yourself I feel like I've learned the
trick it's just now that I know the hype
train is going to hit and be real just
hit the hype train at midnight on Friday
when season two hits of a busy weekend
because you know I have life [ __ ] he
won't have to wait a year for my review
of season two that's on site alright
guys so stranger things season 1 have
you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]